there's a lot of terrifying moment in in
you know in being a ceo in in creating
this crazy venture but at the end of the
day if you're not bold enough you will
never win
and i'm here to win
like
everything right i want to conquer the
world i have bigger vision um so you
need to jump into the water and just
swim
that's it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
let's talk about hr tech with amit
rappaport the co-founder and ceo of
compete after many years working across
most hr roles in the tech and more
specifically the cyber sector amit left
her job to address the biggest pain
point that she had experienced namely a
lack of visibility into real-time
compensation data
now the ceo and co-founder of compete a
fast-growing early stage company she is
dedicated to solving this daily problem
affecting all tech companies of every
size
compete provides hundreds of tech
companies with immediate insights into
complete compensation package data at
the click of a button an energetic and
inspiring leader amit is equally adept
at addressing a conference hall of hr
execs as she is in a room of compete
employees working on the next killer
feature to solve the issue of salary and
benefits benchmarking
i meet
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
how are you great
great thanks so happy that you're here
same here same here we waited for this
right uh for a while we
we waited for this for a while and and
they say that the stuff that you have to
chase after is what is what's going to
be the best and so i'm excited i'm
really excited for this conversation
they're talking
from the rlf offices and no less and
it's going to be an amazing conversation
about compete and about the founding
story of compete and what you're doing
today working with you know companies
around the world to help understand
better what's happening and what's
happening in their domain and
in terms of talent acquisition you know
a lot of questions that are changing
sometimes on a weekly or monthly basis
and so i mean tell me a little bit
daily tell me a little bit about
yourself as well as about compete and
we'll visit both parts of the
conversation as we go along cool so um
amit the co-founder and ceo of compete
compete camp for my personal pain as an
hr i worked as an hr palo alto networks
and it said 101 and i felt the pen that
we're solving now at campaign it
competes sorry dependent
you didn't know how much would you pay
for your potential candidates or to your
existing employees if you're overpaying
and spending the company's budget right
or if you're under paying and putting
yourself at risk if the compensation
packages are attractive and competitive
against the market again the real time
trends and changes so based on the
understanding that all current solutions
are just not good enough and are not
tailored for tech um and that you only
live once right so i've decided to leave
the super comfort zone of sentinel one
which was the best experience ever um
i took six months you know zoom out
refined exactly what i want to solve and
how when covet hit it i had my eureka
moment um called 20 colleagues of mine
they all said yes like a typical uh bald
israeli i said cool the launch will be
in two months back then like no
um name nothing
um it was bold um
dinner time i shared this with my
husband about the statistic of 20 out of
20. um fast forward he's now the
co-founder and cto of compete uh yeah um
we've met uh at palo alto networks
uh he was one of the first engineers at
ceval which was acquired by palo alto um
yeah fast forward like we we launched
the product um
13 like 13 months ago fast forward till
then we have
hundreds of customers uh from the most
from promising startups unicorn ipo the
coolest brands like monday.com up fly
riskify lemonade fiverr gong
and many many more
but now we're operating in globally both
in israel and in the us uh close the
third round led by alef uh together with
vine ventures and other uh private
investors there are more exciting uh
things that i consider at the moment but
stay tuned for more
um and we're a
fine group of 15 bold sharp hungry
fearless people that just want to
conquer the world um
and it's up until now
doing very very good yeah
take me take me 13 months back
the decision to start compete with your
husband
how was that was that a trivial thing
did you have to consider it i mean it
sounds like it's not a such an easy task
to start a company with the spouse
easiest with him yeah i always said that
that he's the maying to my anger and i'm
you know at the end of the day um
creating
our company from scratch it comes with a
lot of unexpected changes and obstacles
along the way and everything um and you
need
to have the best partner both the the
founding kim but both also the
investment the investors as well um you
need the relationship to be built on
trust com like 100 percent trust
um is the one that i respect the most um
i literally admire him so it was it was
the easiest
um
yeah
kickoff incredible and so
you you have your time in political
networks and sentinel one
what tell me a little bit more about
this pain that you're discovering and
more you know more holistically this
pain as a growing trend in the world
what is that what has happened in the
last few years that really made this a
good timing for compete to be born so
that's a very good question because you
know when kovit hit it unfortunately it
impact a lot of businesses um for
competitors just emphasizes the value
prop because at the end of the day now
with all the comp changes
more free capital
um that you need to to grow your company
um the great resignation unfortunately
so it's a literally a candidate for a
talent war that you need
to win this unless you want unless you
won't be exist right um and and compete
enables and empowers our users um to win
the talent competition because now for
the very first time they have the real
time data but it's not just like the
high level that it's tailored for text
so all the
data insights components that we we
provide for our customers are tailored
for the needs that our customers have um
so therefore we're getting a lot of
traction so yeah
i love it and so
you when you started out it started
before covered right
no no it was you know
together we recovered
together with cobot and so you know when
you're starting on you're thinking okay
so there's this pain with talent
acquisition there's a great resignation
people are moving out people are looking
for alternatives which means that
companies are having a tougher time
hiring the right talent what what what
is the gap what is it is it a knowledge
gap is it a negotiations gap where's the
gap
so unfortunately
like
all of the above um i think that at the
end of the day and like this is if we're
talking more about the vision what we're
operating now which is great and so
powerful but this is not the reason why
i i co-founded compete right i have
bigger vision for that um but then
you're saying that
the the bigger chunk of uh the company's
budget spent on the people or related to
that right and you have
zero not minimum you have zero
understanding
of your past performance your current
performance you can predict
because you can't rely on on on the data
that you that you have
um so the understanding of
that is what we want to solve right it's
not just the hiring or the retention is
the understanding that all workforces
that are related to your uh head count
are not based on the data on your past
performance um not on your competitive
landscape um
so
that's the pain that we really want to
solve and we're
working on that
so tell me about the grand vision
if you're looking at compete
you know two three years down the line
maybe even more
where's compete in this world we'll be
the global leader tailored for tech okay
that will enable and empower
um c
cfo ceos uh a chief hr officer to know
exactly about this uh uh 70 of their
budget okay to know exactly what to
predict now 2022 is about to start right
you want to create business plan you
want to know exactly what will what need
to be the route for that okay to end the
year and to meet or to beat the targets
that's exactly what we want to solve
but from your transition in when you
were in hr were you cons
did you have to consider all these
questions and all these budget
allocations and all these scheduling i
mean was
how you know how did you experience this
as an hr person in comparison to what
you're experiencing now so i remember
this you know this sad uh eureka moment
right um
[Music]
you're starting the year uh and you say
okay let's hire 50 employees why like
this no reason no correlation or
or understanding between the the targets
that we set to ourselves the business
targets right sales revenue et cetera
and and what we need to do based on the
performance and everything
and okay we're starting the year all
infrastructure is ready for hiring more
15 plays however dynamic ecosystem tag
as we said um and then two months later
uh all the internal movements promotion
uh maternity leave paternity leave
turnover and now you're running in
circles just to to to make sure that
nothing falls between the cracks right
all the stress and everything
that's exactly what i want to solve okay
um
and do you envision this during envision
this is a platform
for
where companies continue to use it to
sort of as a software in-house
different different aspects of it what
is the most scalable ways you see it for
growing this
oh
like we have many directions because the
data that we collect is basically it's
in the core of every business decision
that you take it's not just hr related
right um so we can take it to many many
directions
and we hear a lot right so the hr
leaders are like asking us to take this
for one direction the cfos are asking to
do to take it to the other the vp rng or
like it depends
um
so at the end of the day i think you
know we'll we'll take it first first and
foremost to where uh like jonathan and i
yoni right the the co-founder of cto um
we have our vision at the same time we
we're making sure that we're on a daily
basis um we're listening and and very
carefully to the feedback that we
receive from our customers which are the
best customers you can wish for
seriously um so i'm pretty i'm i'm
pretty optimistic about the about uh the
vision um and what will the value prop
of cockpit will be
i love it i love it now i i what i
really love hearing more is about you
know challenges from the beginning now
you're starting out
compete and you're coming up with these
you know insight tools for companies
what you know what what are the main
things that are that are bumps in the
road that you just didn't even know to
expect
everything
that's my first time as an entrepreneur
as a ceo
i i didn't know how like
to expect anything seriously anything
besides that the the relationship that i
have with my founder with my founder
right um
i think the fact is that you need to be
bold and brave i can sure it's not just
when you're starting the company for
example the way we tap into new markets
like we did in israel like we're doing
in israel like we're doing now in the
u.s like we'll do in e-mail apec right
is that the first 100 customers because
it's a it's a model if you need to give
some to get some data um so the first
100 customers are free not for good for
12 months just to create the initial
database to drive the buzz about compete
which works for us really really well um
and now for the very first time we
reached the exciting terrifying moment
of renewals right um i need to go back
to all those 100 customers and say their
customers
you saw us live right you saw the
pollution the progression everything
incredible now for the very first time
do you do you see the value prop do you
want to pay for that
i can share that 100
of customers with over 30 employees ask
to renew and the vast majority of them
ask turn you for two years
so there's a lot of terrifying moment in
in you know in being a ceo in in
creating this crazy venture but at the
end of the day if you are not bold
enough you will never win
and i'm here to win like
everything right i want to conquer the
world i have bigger vision um so you
need to jump into the water and just
swim
that's it incredible
i love it when people are thinking of
coming you know to compete you know with
such a good great vision and it's almost
like you're entering a war and you're a
commander and you're leaving a team
that's what that's the energy that i'm
getting here
is really great right for that
yeah
exactly what what are the types of
people that what are the types of people
that you
[Music]
that
that you're looking for you know types
of personalities etc
of my employees
my team members
of the team members of the people that
you're looking to hire because you know
as a 15 people you're going to continue
growing and you're going to continue
looking for great people and i mean
here's what what what types of people
would you personally i mean to be
interested to partner with as you're
continuing on this war so i must say
that the answer is not just for
employees it's for my investors too okay
the type of people that i'm i want to on
board to this crazy slash
fun venture is
the bald people the fearless people the
one that can
just take the hammer and break the wall
right
that's the way i believe uh you need to
create the reality don't wait for things
to to get along no you want something go
and and and and create that or achieve
that um that's the kind of people team
members how do you test for that i mean
how do you how do you besides asking
them are you bold are you brave how do
you go and figure out if a person that
you're about to hire is is exactly that
so first i have like you know years of
experiences leading the recruitment
that's an hr right
so you know exactly what the kind of a
question that you want to ask and you
listen very
carefully to the to their answers uh
with investors you can see who's bold
and like um runs the entire process like
with fearless uh uh um
five right um so you you can you can
sense it at the end of the day
um you can that's easy to see um
and look at the end of the day i will
make mistake right i'm only humane i'll
make many mistakes the the thing
that i think it's very powerful as a ceo
is first and foremost to run fast but at
the same time
to to adopt to change while you're
running um that makes a ceo to be
extremely powerful
and
up until now i i did it very
successfully so um
i i love it and we're gonna have to do a
whole episode just on figuring out where
you're getting your energy from because
it's addicting and it's and it's very
very cool i mean take me back but i will
say like
my partner he's like thirsty he's mine
to me
i love it take me back
way way away before complete before paul
to network before sentinel one
who who is the meat you know growing up
middle school elementary school you know
what what really makes you curious as
you go you know as a kid on this earth
i was born in the kibbutz um i think and
my childhood was extremely
plain and simple you know uh climbing on
avocado trees and stuff like that um i
think what um
taught me to be like
the entrepreneur that i am now is the
fact that um my two parents uh left the
kibbutz uh 40 years old with literally
zero money in their pockets three kids
um
and the fact that you know um
they set
the them um
their targets and their dreams and they
never gave up on that right they just
said okay we want to live with passion
um um and we want to live the the dream
that we want to to create right um so
that taught me a lot along the way um so
i'm a very hard worker you can ask my ex
colleagues and palo alto
and my uh employees now um and i believe
that's the only way you can achieve uh
um
the things that you want to achieve you
need to work hard um you need to set
yourself super aggressive milestones
super aggressive targets right and work
hard um
i love it
and the inspiration today so
you know beyond just the mission of
helping other companies and and and
providing those insights and
making everything more accessible what
where's your personal inspiration coming
from you wake up every day to leave this
ship you have to get all this energy
something you mentioned that everything
is challenging and then most things are
first time as a first-time entrepreneur
where is the inspiration coming from i'm
coming for i think it's coming from uh
two um
parameters or something first and
foremost it's seriously
third time is the turn that's the third
time i'm saying that but for my partner
um but on top of that it's for my kids i
think that for the very first time they
see me um
and they and like they're extremely
proud um all the time like that that
nine years old is asking are you happy
like uh the phone rings and then oh
another another customer joined it's
it's their day-to-day experience and
that's insane
the other day we uh uh
um we went somewhere and he asked me um
mommy what's the situation like how many
customers do you have now and i said we
have hundreds and it was before the the
um the launch in the usa so he said nine
years old and i said wow so impressive
so just imagine what will be once you're
uh launching the us so and then i said
okay
they understand that right um
and this is something that when i worked
with parallel and sentinel one like the
high-end tech companies that's for sure
but
they didn't felt about they didn't feel
about this uh about me right
and for the very first time there are
like the proudest kids ever um i love it
oh yeah i love it if you have to
describe yourself in a few words who how
how would people describe a meat
i think partner
um authentic and bold for sure
thank you very very much
compete sounds incredible it sounds like
an incredible journey most of all
and i have no idea that no no doubt that
you're going to make a huge huge impact
and that you're going to make a lot a
lot of companies a very happy which
already are doing hey but thank you very
much and best of luck thank you thank
you so much
you